je veux surtout pas qu'on emploie le
terme rh parce que c'est un terme
tellement lourd tellement juridique
tellement salariale que non c'est pas
possible donc dans le monde bénévolat
c'est je m'occupe des bénévoles jeu-là
bénévoles qui s'occupent des vols cela
fait douze ans que sandrine vincent 51
ans maman de deux enfants et habitante
de chambourcy est bénévole au sein des
restos du coeur dans les yvelines
d'abord directrice commerciale salariés
dans l'immobilier ou encore dans les
assurances puis 10 ans d'expatriation à
l'étranger en rentrant sandrine se lance
et intègre l'association
quand je suis rentré j'avais un peu une
rupture de réseau en fait professionnels
sociaux enfin c'était compliqué
les enfants ont grandi un peu le
syndrome du nid vide et un matin ceux
d'yvon ça peut plus durer
la banquette c'est bien mais je veux
donner un sens à mes journées les restos
mon convenu parce qu'il y avait sur
cette notion de d'indépendance politique
religieuse je n'avais pas l'impression
d'adhérer à ni un parti ni à une
conviction en 2009 sandrine commence par
un poste administratif
mais très vite le terrain l'appel elle
passe trois ans au sein du centre
d'accueil de vernouillet aujourd'hui
elle forme les bénévoles au terrain mais
aussi à l'esprit restos j'oriente monde
est né vaut là vers les bénévoles
que ce soit pour le recrutement que ce
soit pour la formation que ce soit pour
leur parcours au sein des restos mon
souci c'est qu'ils vivent bien leur
bénévolat parce que c'est pas tous les
jours facile
sans bénévole est pas la sauce donc je
mets toute mon énergie
j'essaye ma bonne humeur et parfois
certains phrasés pourra pour que tout le
monde se porte au mieux avec la crise
sanitaire beaucoup de choses ont changé
mais pas l'envi de sandrine de
poursuivre sa mission entre adaptation
au confinement aux mesures barrières et
re motivation des troupes
on a eu un temps de sidération d'une
quinzaine de jours assez compliqué on a
tous suspendus un peu et puis un moment
donné on s'est dit fou y retourner quoi
c'est pas possible donc on a mis en
place un système pendant toute la
période de confinement de colis on a
fait 69
avec de la musique avec des rires avec
du froid mais on s'en fichait ont
retrouvé des humains et on avait besoin
de retrouver des humains on est toujours
très vigilant sur une nounou respect de
mesures sanitaires tout en mettant de
plus en plus d'humains ou d'humanité
dans ces masques et dans ses contacts
compliqué donc c'est voilà notre
priorité pour ce début d'année c'est ça
chaque année les restos du coeur 78
accueille environ 15000 personnes pour
1200 bénévoles
ce week end c'est la grande collecte
nationale sandrine comme tous les autres
sera évidemment sur le bout